Michael caman author of American culture
American tastes social change and the
20th century what is your book about
it's about the growth of leisure in the
20th century and how Americans use their
leisure the changing ways in which they
use their leisure the changing ways in
which the growth of disposable income
affected the way they use their leisure
the changing ways in which the
relationship between education and
socioeconomic status affected people's
sense of what books they ought to be
reading what films they ought to be
seeing what musical events they ought to
be attending and the way in which in the
second half of the 20th century
especially the lines began to get very
very blurred we're very customed to
hearing the phrases highbrow middlebrow
lowbrow that were in constant use during
the first sort of six decades of the
20th century they're still in use they
haven't been entirely discarded but now
just a few months ago there was a very
interesting article called the graying
of the high brow because most of the
according to this article which was
pretty well-informed the high brows tend
to be older and it's not that younger
people have no interest in opera or
symphonic music but they have many many
other interests as well and you can't
people are increasingly difficult to
categorize and in the book I love to use
the I love to quote Duke Ellington's
phrase beyond category which he was
using in a slightly different way but my
belief is that the tastes of most people
are now beyond category this is a book
about changes in taste levels in the
United States all right let's say that
you and I are going to have a highbrow
night or do something highbrow what's
that mean it means that we might very
well go to the Opera
we might even sit around and discuss
compare the performance of that
performance of Rigoletto with other
performances of Riggle oh that we've
seen because we are Opera buffs it
mean that we go to a reading discussion
group where everyone has agreed we meet
once a month at different the homes of
different people and we've all tried to
work our way through James Joyce's
Ulysses let's say or at least 50 pages
of it for that month we get together and
we try to sort out the uses of language
and the allusions and the images I think
those would be representative examples
of what we might do together on a
highbrow evening what do we do if we're
going to have a middlebrow evening
little brave nning might still involve
getting together to discuss a book but
the book would more likely be perhaps a
novel by Ernest Hemingway
this was some years back or more
recently let's say John Updike there's a
very the broader range of taste
preferences in the middle bra category
we might very well get together to go
see if it's the 1950s kismet or South
Pacific we might very well more recently
go see bring on denoise bring on the
funk or or
a lively Broadway musical that that
incorporates rock but in a fairly
sophisticated way into the musical
entertainment
all right the obvious what we do if it's
a lowbrow night
if the Lobo we might go on a pub crawl
but there there can be up in middlebrow
pub crawls there's a pub crawl we might
very well go to a baseball game and
pretty grungy clothes and drink a fair
amount of beer and if it's a guys night
out
we might use some language that we
wouldn't ordinarily use around the house
who determines what's highbrow
middlebrow lowbrow Once Upon a Time
cultural critics in the United States
really made a difference and they were
key determinants so were so were faculty
members at universities that people
attended and in college people got a
pretty clear sense from their professors
of
what was highbrow and what was not and
there tended to be a cleavage between
highbrow and virtually everything else
that that began to change quite
dramatically and now in colleges you may
have courses devoted to aspects of
popular culture and even mass culture so
that the menu that that students can can
look at when they attend college today
is vast compared to the menu of 50 years
ago or 75 years ago but going back to
the cultural critics because culture the
history of cultural criticism in the
twentieth century is one of the subjects
that that lured me into writing this
book I became quite interested in the
history of cultural criticism because I
previously written a biography of a very
important cultural critic named Gilbert
SEL DS who was one of the very first to
argue in the 1920s that popular culture
should be taken quite seriously and
having done an in-depth study of him I
wanted to get a more panoramic view of
who the important cultural critics have
been whether it's George Jean Nathan and
Nathan in theater or HL Mencken and
literary criticism and social criticism
and one of the things I found is that
cultural critics for example in the mid
twentieth century they could make or
break a show if Walter Kerr on opening
night attended a Broadway drama and
panned it the next day that show might
very well close within two weeks if he
loved it the subscriptions for tickets
would be simply extraordinary and one of
the things that I argue in the book is
that on the one hand there's been a
proliferation of cultural critics in
many different areas that that simply
didn't have and enjoy serious criticism
half a century ago but on yet for
example the New York Times well now now
has reviews of rock concerts and and
jazz performances and folk concerts that
the New York Times would not have
imagined reviewing four or five decades
ago so cultural critics are flourishing
they are numerous
not they don't begin to have the taste
making clout that they did half a
century ago and that in my view is
because what I call cultural power has
increasingly come to trump cultural
authority and so without whether it's
whether it's Disney or various networks
various sorts of entities that are
extraordinarily sensitive to to
sponsorship to advertising to ratings
and that are fiercely competitive are
calling the shots and you can have shows
like cats
for example that receive very negative
reviews from critics but nonetheless
flourish incredibly so that the the one
of the trajectories that I attempt to
trace in the book is what has been the
role of cultural critics in our society
in the 20th century what part of the
world you live in right now I live in
basically I've spent my life in three
places Washington DC Cambridge
Massachusetts and Ithaca New York where
I've been since 1965 what did you do
here in Washington I was born in
Rochester New York but I was brought
here in 1941 and I lived here from 1941
I went to primary school secondary
secondary school graduated from Calvin
Coolidge high school in 1954 went to
George Washington University graduated
in 1958 and they went off to graduate
school where I pursued graduate study in
American history at Harvard at Harvard
and you've been teaching at Cornell
since 1965 exactly you were at one point
president of the organization of
American historian but what is that
organization do it's an organization of
about 12,000 members it sponsors an
annual conference to which members come
and present papers and listen to papers
on a wide array of subjects in American
history and comparative history it
publishes the Journal of record in the
field of American history which includes
both scholarly articles but also every
book that has bears any relationship to
American
history whether it's published in the
United States or Mexico or Africa or
Asia any book about American history
they at least attempt to review there
some especially published outside the
United States fall between the cracks
but the review section of that journal
has gotten quite enormous they also
publish a a journal aimed at secondary
school teachers of history who and often
thematic issues devoted entirely to
Chicano history or african-american
history or women's history to bring
secondary school teachers up to speed on
the latest developments in scholarship
so they can then translate that into the
courses that they're teaching in both
public and private schools in the United
States so their variety of functions the
organization serves how much power do
historians have to tell us what really
happened in history how much power if
they write reasonably well they can
attract a very considerable audience if
they write on subjects that grab the
public's attention so that when Steven
Ambrose a couple of years ago published
a book on Lewis and Clark a fascinating
subject that that had a kind of
panoramic view of the country and the
exploration of the country early in the
19th century this historian with a PhD
with an academic background made the
bestseller list there are other
historians who for a variety of reasons
bright on subjects of much more limited
interest but it's it's quite fascinating
to watch the way some books that tend to
be ignored when they first appear can
become building blocks when others on
related subjects begin to appear and
eventually will filter down for example
they'll find their way into into college
textbooks or high school textbooks and
profoundly affect the public's awareness
of the American past of those 12,000
professors that were part of the
Organization of American storage how
many of them you think would choose
first and foremost as their featured
entertainment highbrow
Oh today uh probably a minority I know
that there are many upper lovers and and
lovers of serious music and lovers of
serious drama but I think I am fairly
representative in the blurring of my own
taste so perhaps it's immodest but I'll
simply indicate that I love to hear a
chamber music group play classical or
pre classical music on period
instruments but I also love bluegrass I
also love blues and jazz I can be a
couch potato and watch football and
basketball endlessly the month of March
when the NCAA tournament is on is a
total loss for me because I can't stop
watching that and I think I would say
that's fairly representative that that
mix of tastes that are middlebrow
lowbrow highbrow I think is fairly
characteristic of most members 100 years
ago if you had 12,000 history professors
would it be the same no no I think
people were much more well first of all
the range of entertainment options was
incredibly limited 100 years ago and
that's one of the biggest differences
the choices that Americans have in terms
of how they're going to use their
leisure time is is dramatically
different than it was a century ago and
I hope that comes through very clearly
in the book
in addition Americans had a very strong
sense of what America the the educated
American historian had a very strong
sense of what it was appropriate for him
or her to do a good example that I can
cite involves the world Columbian
Exposition at Chicago in 1893
that's when Frederick Jackson Turner
perhaps the most famous or one of the
most famous historians in in
the entire flow of American historical
writing gave his famous paper on the
role of the frontier in American history
he presented that paper to a counterpart
organization the American Historical
Association in within the confines of
the white what was called the white city
this spectacular pristine elegant but
not permanent enclosure that was
designed to commemorate the 400th
anniversary of the so-called discovery
of America out on the Midway Plaisance
outside of the White City something else
involving the American West was going on
and that was Buffalo Bill Cody doing his
wildly popular Wild West Show but the
segregation of that but it's an
anachronism to use it but the
segregation of that middlebrow or even
lowbrow event to the Midway Plaisance
outside of the white city and Frederick
Jackson Turner giving his speech within
the confines of the white city as an
indication I think of how
compartmentalised things were a century
ago and I think that you your
prototypical historian that you're
referring to would have been very happy
listening to Turner and might have felt
a little bit uncomfortable being at the
Wild West Show how much do politicians
have to say about today's cultural
tastes well they have a fair amount in
terms of regulatory responsibilities
whether it's through the FCC or signals
that they send to various regulatory
agencies we have we have a very
interesting history particularly since
the 1950s of periodic concern on the
part of politicians with the amount of
violence sexual activity profanity and
so forth appearing on television people
may think that that's a 1990s phenomenon
but back in the 1950s a psychiatrist
named Frederic wertham became obsessed
with the belief that comic books which
were really quite a new phenomena at the
time the first Superman comic only
appeared at the end of the 1930s and
comic books flourished during World War
two because they they played on
stereotypes of Japanese being
caricatured in a certain way as the bad
guys and the Americans as the good guys
and there was a tremendous amount of
violence in comic books during World War
two and then there was even more after
but more of a domestic nature in terms
of crime and so on and so forth with
them raise such a hue and cry that
senator Estes Kefauver held hearings and
Frank Stanton the president of CBS was
called before that that that committee
to testify and to justify the
programming that was appearing on CBS
other other network executives were were
called to testify and that that has
recurred at in a cyclical way at about
fifteen to twenty year intervals over
the past half-century so the concern
that we've seen expressed so often
especially by politicians who are
running for something in the 1990s is
not a new story biting and they're doing
it right now exactly and I bring it up
to ask you whether or not when they have
hearings on this stuff and whether
Hollywood's creating these problems or
television or does it have any impact on
what we eventually see or hear on radio
until not in the long term the what what
what began to happen when these first
hearings were held in the 1950s is that
CBS would cool it for a while for about
six months things would get toned down
and then they would go right back to
normal if we scroll back another 20
years you get the interesting
introduction of the production code on
film the the early Mae West films in the
early 1930s got a little bit too raunchy
for certain segments of the society the
Catholic Church in particular was was
very very disturbed and so the
production code was brought into effect
in 1934 and Hollywood was did it did an
interesting thing
they were forced to toe the line and
they turned to history among other
things costume dramas history was
considered safe because it was something
was happening back in the 17th or the
18th century people were in costume and
even though their might might have been
a seduction scene or even violence in a
Hollywood movie made in the later 1930s
or Clark Gable taking off his shirt and
not wearing an undershirt and gone to
the wind that might have been looked at
askance but because it's it's set during
the American Civil War and people
thought that this was at the time that
this is a fairly authentic
representation of what it might have
been like during the Civil War that
passed muster so we've gone through
these endless cycles not merely with
television but with film as well what's
your reaction to something like the chip
that was voted by Congress to be put in
television sets to be able to determine
what comes into your home well as with
as with attempts now to control what's
accessible on the Internet the World
Wide Web there are really interesting
First Amendment problems with that I as
as a parent and now as a grandparent I
happen to be in favor of the chip but I
understand and respect the the concerns
First Amendment specialists who worry
about about this kind of regulation but
it's it's a little-known fact that in
1915 the Supreme Court ruled that the
film industry was not covered by the
First Amendment that decision insisted
or or declared that this was that film
was an expression a commercial
expression of entertainment and was not
covered by the freedom of speech that we
associate with the First Amendment
needless to say that changed over time
but again it's an old it's an old story
and getting a sense of historical
perspective I think is important what do
you teach I teach an undergraduate
lecture course on American culture
the 1880s to the present which is
partially how I got into writing this
book I had to come to terms with a vast
amount that's been written about the
history of film the history of music the
history of sports and so forth so I give
that as a lecture course I give a
seminar for honor students pursuing an
undergraduate degree in history I teach
a an undergraduate seminar for juniors
and seniors and the topic changes from
year to year for the last couple of
years the topic has been very closely
connected to this book but it's next
spring it will move on to my next
project which is the four seasons and
there will be a seminar about the four
seasons in art and literature what do
you see and your college students you
teach it's different from what it was
1965 oh that's a good question
they are they are wonderfully bright at
Cornell University
they are conscientious they are diligent
hard-working they are socially far more
mature than students were when I began
teaching at Harvard and Cornell in the
mid 1960s they are sophisticated there
has been that's all the good news the
bad news is that there's been a dramatic
decline in the quality of their writing
which is not new news everyone has heard
this before this is a very visually
oriented generation they are not asked
to write as much as they were when you
and I were in high school or in college
and in a seminar for example this honors
seminar that I'm teaching this semester
20 superb students it it'll be another
five weeks before I see the first piece
of written work and right now I have a
very very positive view of these
wonderfully engaging students and I know
that I will undergo a kind of culture
shock when I see their first their first
written work because it will not match
the impression that one has of their
intelligence in part they simply don't
take the pains with their writing
papers are often written in the last 24
hours before they're due in some
instances they rely excessively on
spellcheck and you get some very weird
because so much is being composed on the
computer you get some very very odd
glitches or poor peculiar pieces of
phrasing and so on so the students are
basically a delight but but writing is a
serious problem you have a quote in them
it's not actually a quote but it's you
all right maybe it is we're talking
about Irving Kristol and it does start
with a quote Marxist some someone has to
be able to say with assurance and a
measure of authority what is culture and
what is not what is decent and what is
not there must be some group or class
that is admittedly competent to decide
not without error but more wiser than
anyone else questions of moral and
cultural value you have any idea what
year he said that I could look it up and
they doesn't say here what yet is what
what page is the first it's on page 147
it should be a footnote I think he I
think he said that in the 1960s I'm
pretty sure but I'm not sure it matters
but let me read that again there must be
some group or class that is admittedly
more that is admittedly competent to
decide not without error but more wiser
than anyone else questions of moral and
cultural value my question to you is do
you agree with that well I'm pretty sure
by the way he wrote that during the
during the 1960s when sort of all what's
the right phrase no holds barred or the
rules were dramatically changing in
terms of determining taste at first
people were horrified velvet by Elvis
Presley or horrified by the Beatles and
then all there was a remarkable swing I
certainly agree with him in the sense
that there there ought to be a place for
cultural critics of every conceivable
kind I think they feel a very very
useful function in our society I cannot
I cannot watch or attend all of the
things that I would like to watch or ten
concerts films dramatic productions this
recording of Beethoven's Ninth Symphony
as opposed to that performance of
Beethoven's Ninth Symphony so it's very
useful to have to have people with
expertise rendering judgment but there
are there are problems of two sorts
first often ones one one one one man's
meat is another man's poison and what
one person likes for very idiosyncratic
reasons may not necessarily be the best
reasons for preferring that performance
the other the other problem that I have
with with cristal statement which many
others William Bennett and others would
certainly agree with is that there tends
to be an intolerance with with modes of
cultural expression that they regard as
degrading or vulgar for example hip-hop
and rap
I do not know mr. Kristol but my guess
is that he probably does not care for it
there's a very wonderful scholar named
Tricia Rose who's done a terrific book a
couple of years ago called black noise
in which he explains socially and
culturally where hip-hop and rap came
from she and she devotes her last
chapter to female rappers there are many
more than I ever imagined one of the
criticisms of rap is that it's it's it's
misogynist and Tricia Rose who is a
feminist explains at least she tries to
understand why the male rappers say some
of the things that they say about the
sisters and I am sure we'll put it let's
just put it this way I would not want
when Krystal
to be the last word on the cultural
value and significance of rap and
hip-hop would you want Tricia Rose to be
yeah yeah because she understands it
she's gotten inside of it she's grown up
with it she know she she knows what it's
all about she make excuses for the man
and what they say absolutely not
absolutely not
she well that's in the eye of the
beholder she makes excuses in the sense
that she she points out the number of
young black males who have been in
prison or have been abused by white
police authorities she tries to explain
the socio-economic circumstances that
some of these people have grown up in
but by no means does she thereby condone
some of the most misogynist lyrics that
one finds in rap on this same page you
also bring up Stewart Alsop who died in
1974 Easter right for Newsweek used to
do a column with his brother Joseph and
you say here that Stewart Alsop were
respected and widely syndicated
columnist who was the American
aristocrat incarnate educated at Groton
and Yale the moan near the end of his
life in 1974 the decline of the old wasp
elite because it is meant the loss of
political and cultural Authority in
general he believed that their clout had
started to wane in 1953 under Eisenhower
when non elite people began to run the
American government also hated to
contemplate his beloved country as a
society without authority meaning of
course Authority as he had known it in
the guise of men like Dean Acheson
there's a lot in that perfect what what
does it say to you what it says to me is
that I grew up reading The Washington
Post every day and reading Joan Stewart
Alsop skolem and I I found them very
engaging on politics I did not find them
very engaging on the subject of culture
they were two extremely well educated
and thoughtful men who were incredible
snobs Joe more than more than Stewart
they were absolute cultural snobs
about people as well as various aspects
of cultural performance and what's
interesting is that or I think ought to
be pointed out is that that is one
perspective that one finds in the old
wasp elite but there are other people
like George Plimpton or man named tro T
ro w of the old wasps Bailey who have
sort of gone with the flow and are much
more discriminating they they too can be
critical of newer phenomena in popular
culture but they don't reject it all and
plimpton whether it's it's playing
hockey or trying to play football or try
to experience what popular culture is
all about that's what Joe and Stewart
Alsop I couldn't do they they clustered
themselves away in their Georgetown
enclaves only seeing the right people
going to the right things and I prefer
the the George Plimpton root for four
members of the old wasp a lead in your
acknowledgement section you say during
1997 1998 I enjoyed the good fortune of
a fellowship from the National Endowment
for the Humanities what was the
fellowship for fellowship was to was
each year the endowment Awards I don't
know if I forget the exact number
fellowships to college and university
professors to pursue their research or
to bring the research to fruition in the
form of a book and in my case the I had
been doing research for this project
ever since the late 1980s so 97 98 was a
year writing year for me and it was it
provided me with the I had sabbatical
leave from Cornell that year
Cornell paid half my salary neh paid
less than half but in but it made it
possible for me to take the entire year
off and bring the book to completion it
also says here that the you have we were
guest scholar at the Woodrow Wilson
international center to do what three to
two
that made up the rest of my salary so
that I was not a money-losing year
and I was able to both to use that time
to complete this book and also to
complete a book a biography of an artist
named Robert Gwathmey whose whose art
has fascinated me for a long time and in
fact I worked on the book about Robert
Gwathmey during basically the same time
period and I would move back and forth
between the two projects this this book
was was terribly difficult to do for a
variety of reasons the grummy book at
least by comparison was relatively easy
so when I was working on this book and I
would get stuck absolutely stuck and to
know what to do next
I would turn to the guava project and
then come back to this with some fresh
perspective also I thought I saw her I
can't pull her up right not to something
you did for the Smithsonian Institution
I've done a number of things
well I served for six years as a member
of the Smithsonian Council which is a
kind of oversight body that annually
visits several components the
Smithsonian has 16 bureaus and each year
with the the secretary which is the
title of the director would select
perhaps the National Zoo and the
National Museum of American history and
the National Air and Space Museum and
the council would spend three days
meeting with curators historians zoo
keepers and talking about getting a
sense of of challenges problems
opportunities and then we would write a
lengthy report and set of
recommendations for the director and for
the Board of Regents of the Smithsonian
so that was a six year commitment to the
Smithsonian in addition I was fortunate
enough to hold a Regents fellowship from
the Smithsonian in 1990 and that meant
that I was housed at the National
Portrait Gallery which is actually
considered a History Museum and that
provided me with the opportunity to
complete a book called mystic chords of
memory very very long book about a
number of major shifts in American
culture that occurred largely in the
19th and 20th centuries in all those
cases its institutions that have some
tax payer underwriting yes and the
reason I bring it up is to ask you what
do you think of the process
where the taxpayer brings money into the
pot and then they give it out to
different historical projects and are
you comfortable that we're getting a
balanced presentation by the people that
are writing history through government
grants yes I am comfortable with it
because there first of all there it what
many people do not understand is that
there's a very scrupulous peer-review
project process I'm sorry that occurs
and the applications for any given year
come in and then a panel is brought to
Washington I serve on one of those
panels this summer it's sort of the I
guess it's the price you pay for for
having a grant they get you the next
year and so I on a panel that reviewed
48 applications and we spent in each
each member of the panel took a bit took
us about four days to go very very
carefully through each of those
applications then we came to Washington
and spent one full day going over them
and evaluating them and not once not not
not once during the course of the
meeting of the five panelists did
anything ideological or political enter
into the discussion purely on the merits
the significance the ability or the
ability of this particular applicant to
bring that project to completion was it
too grandiose and therefore not likely
to ever seek fruition was it too micro
to really be significant to more than
four other individuals how original was
the proposal but ideology and politics
never ever entered into the discussion
was the islet cell balanced politically
I can't answer that because I don't know
the politics of I knew I knew one of the
panelists previously I had never met the
other three and I have no idea what
their politics are it never in never
surfaced and who decides who decides who
decide to decide we panel the panel
makes recommendations we essentially
rank the
and those rankings go to a national
council both the National Endowment for
the Humanities and the National
Endowment for the Arts have councils of
I think some 26 members and the the
staff members of NEA and neh who
themselves are usually people with
doctorates in an array of fields or at
least at NIH and NEA they're perhaps
less likely to in some some instances to
have doctorates and they review our
recommendations they may add explanatory
or contextual material for presentation
to the National Council and then
ultimately it's up to the chair of neh
now William Farris previously Sheldon
Hackney to make the final call on one
who receives a fellowship I don't know
if I'm going to make clear about this
but let me then take based on your book
talking about who decides in this
country what's right and wrong and up
and down in hybra the number one rated
television today in cable a week after
week is wrestling it's a newest it's a
fairly new phenomenon where almost
anything on wrestling that goes on cable
it's a revived phenomenon it will go up
to the top of the rating and I would I
just wonder if what people in academia
and you talk about academia a lot in
here think about that and what is that
what's that trend mean you think it's
good question if people by the way who
went to those Monday night and Friday
night wrestling events we're at your
table deciding who would write the
history would it be different oh sure
sure it would be there are there is no
consensus among academics in response to
the question that you have just raised
there are populist academics very
strongly anti elitist who would say to
you if that's what those people want to
watch it's not for us to tell them that
they should be watching the New York
Philharmonic or listening to the NIR
Philharmonic or watching Baryshnikov or
or whatever if that's what gives them
pleasure
they know it's hokey they know it's
staged it's not as though they're being
duped they know it is a form of staged
entertainment and if that's what they
enjoy they're entitled to to watch it
there's a very different perspective
that you would get and they're more than
just two perspectives but but for
reasons of time let's just concentrate
on two there's also perspective which
which is is quite old goes back at least
40 or 50 years that that urges that we
ought to try to level up that we ought
to try to achieve in our culture what
any number of people called Democratic
distinction that is to say that culture
should be of the people by the people
for the people but that people really
would like and want better entertainment
than hokey stage wrestling if they were
if it was offered to them and those
people are likely to be accused of being
a leader by the populace that I've just
referred to but those are perhaps two
two ends of the spectrum there's one
other angle which I don't entirely agree
with and I talked about some length in
the book there's another strong emphasis
that the populace have and that is that
programs that many people might not
approve of as being culturally valuable
or significant or worthwhile are not
necessarily swallowed whole and digested
in their entirety that people the the
fashionable word in a khadeem now is
appropriate people take from soap operas
or situation comedies Dallas Baywatch
whatever people take whether it's within
the Hispanic community or the
african-american community or different
different subcultures in the United
States people take aspects of what they
watch and they rework it into their own
lives in in meaningful ways
you also get this argument from people
who spend a lot of time studying fans
like Trekkies who have Star Trek
conventions and they collect Star Trek
memorabilia and they communicate with
one another about particular Star
correct programs that didn't end the way
these individuals felt they should have
been and they actually rewrite they
write alternative scripts so the
argument is that there is there's
there's a populist engagement with mass
and popular culture and it's not just
passively swallowed whole so that's
that's one response that you would get
to to your question about your taking
wrestling as a symptomatic example of
something that we might consider coarse
vulgar stupid and and and one response
that you would get as well people know
that and they react respond to in
different ways you have different
graphics arts photographs you've got
this painting in here by James Wyeth so
much Jamie why that's Jimmy with who now
likes to be called James now he's not is
not so young anymore purpose of this in
your book Oh
the purpose of it is that I at that
point I've actually talked about Andy
Warhol a couple of times in an earlier
chapter and now in this chapter and even
though I'm not particularly a Warhol fan
after reading a lot about Warhol I've
come to the Ruth to the realisation that
there is no figure in in American pop
culture more influential pop culture and
especially in the arts in the graphic
arts no figure more influential than
Warhol has been since the late 1960s
early 70s and the number of artists
whose names really don't mean very much
to us because they're still fairly
obscure who in one way or another
directly indirectly secondarily have
have had their careers their their
objectives their agendas shaped by
Warhol
opportunities opened for them by Warhol
the very idea that consumerism and
commodification could be a subject of
art proper subject for art so the mass
production of brillo boxes and so on it
could be a subject of art has had an
enormous impact on on American artists
and there's this Norman Rockwell
painting of the new television set 1947
why is this 49 I'm sorry
isn't it 49 yeah you're right wait why
is this here it's there because I I'm I
I do argue in the book that television
is the single most pivotal turning point
in terms of the impact of technology on
American leisure on American advertising
and that its impact changed quite
swiftly during the during the first
decade of its existence at first it was
quite expensive and only the elite could
afford it if you own one most of the
folks on your block would probably come
to your house on ask if they can we
please come to your house at eight
o'clock on Tuesday night so we can watch
Milton Berle er or whatever by the late
50s the saturation of American homes
with one television set at least was
quite remarkable and television went
within a decade from being a luxury to
being considered a necessity babysitting
purposes and so on but there are other
social changes that came along as well
for example initially television brought
families together because televisions
were not portable they were big console
things they sat in a room that now
became the focal point of the home the
family room and Families mommy daddy and
the kids would all sit together in the
1950s and watch a program but with
passage of time as we get into the 60s
70s and 80s and it became Nora t'v for a
family to have two and sometimes even
three televisions mom and dad might be
in the family room watching their
program and sixteen-year-old sis is in
her / room watching program of her
choice
12
well Johnny is in his room and what that
exemplifies is what we call the
privatization of culture and for me one
of the big differences between popular
culture and mass culture is that popular
culture was interactive and
participatory and mass culture has this
privatizing effect this is Hollywood
1937 by Thomas Hart Benton what's this
mean it's a wonderful example of the
contest between cultural Authority and
cultural power Benton was brought to
Hollywood or was invited to come to
Hollywood he was a very well-known one
of the leading most prominent American
artists of the day he was invited to
come to Hollywood and sort of hang out
and paint something and he painted this
picture in 1937 Jean Harlow the flashy
blonde movie star had died earlier that
year and so she is she's the scantily
clad figure in the very center although
they're actually in the foreground it's
hard to see but in the foreground
there's a woman whose breasts are
entirely bare but she's a little bit
more discretely presented and Life
magazine had intended originally to
print what Benton painted as a result of
his experience in Hollywood when they
saw this picture in 1937 they decided
well this is not an appropriate image to
appear in a family magazine and so they
killed it about 6 months later that
painting won a major juried competition
in Pittsburgh put on by the Carnegie
Museum of Art in Pittsburgh and it sort
it suddenly became the painting of the
year at that point
Life magazine reversed itself and said
well if the critics say this is really
good art and it is after all by Thomas
Hart Benton we better run it so they ran
it in a huge double page bleeding off
the sheets spread and that was an
instance in the 1930s of cultural
Authority trumping
cultural power which couldn't happen or
is much less likely to happen 50 years
later me the people HL Mencken 1949 by
Al Hirschfeld we still alive
very much alive AG Omega many hours 94
or 95 and this was done by a relatively
young Al Hirschfeld Menken was
wonderfully caustic he was a wonderfully
engaging curmudgeon but and during the
1920s he was the most respected and the
most engaging the most eagerly awaited
in terms of his columns in the american
mercury cultural critic in the united
states during the 1930s and 40s he
became increasingly conservative he was
pro german he was from a German American
family and he became increasingly
curmudgeonly and increasingly
egotistical
so what Hirschfeld is doing with that
caricature in the 1940s is saying
HL Mencken may be a very smart man and
he did make an extraordinary
contribution to American culture by by
compiling his five-volume history of the
american language and of american
language usage but Hirschfeld is saying
despite all that he's become the horse's
ass one of the most quoted men in your
book alexis de tocqueville yeah why
because he anticipated a lot of things
that turned out to be true among them
for example the privatization of culture
in the United States he was he was very
concerned that in a society where
individualism was so prized
eventually that could lead to a kind of
atomization and fragmentation of society
and culture and not everyone but many
social critics in our own time lament
precisely that on the other hand
Tocqueville's
other great emphasis was upon equality
and he was as a French aristocrat he was
he was
rather ambivalent about what he
considered the American obsession with
equality and where it would lead would
it lead for example would when an
emphasis upon equality lead to a
diminution of Liberty and that's one of
the great great debates of our own time
for example with regard to affirmative
action if if we try to absolutely level
the playing field
does that mean that certain white males
are not going to be able to get into
medical schools so Tocqueville was
prophetic on many scores and and he is
eminently quotable this man also
probably says much quoted as Alexis de
Tocqueville in your book Russell Lin's
lines lines Russell 18-49 highbrow
middlebrow lowbrow what do you do uh all
of the above
he was the associate editor of Harper's
Magazine and in February of 1949 he
published an essay in Harper's in which
he divided Americans into four not three
but four taste level categories highbrow
upper middle brow lower middle brow and
low brow life maggot that that that
essay attracted a lot of interest it was
fun lines usually wrote tongue-in-cheek
and Life magazine decided hey let's
let's run with this so they commissioned
Tom funk to create this chart based on
lines is essay and Life magazine in
April of 1949 ran this forty four the
these forty four items categorizing
people by what they like to drink what
they like to wear how they like to
furnish their homes etc and that that
chart and that piece in Life magazine
that was really the result of a
collaboration between Russell lines and
Tom funk who is still alive became the
most popular parlor game in the United
States for about a year and a half and
people you asked me much earlier what we
do tonight if we were such and such well
people would sit around after dinner and
they would devote an entire evening
saying oh you like bourbon and ginger
ale then you must be a lower-middle brow
and and so on and at colleges plays were
written based upon Russell Lines's brow
level categorization and so forth and
what's what's what's so ironic is that
all of the attention that Lines's Chart
received would give you the impression
that this was sort of a hyper high point
of rigid categorization of Americans by
taste levels when in reality the 1950s
was exactly the decade when things began
to blur when when people when it became
less and less possible to categorize
people because as I was saying earlier
they may have liked some highbrow things
some upper-middle browse things and so
forth to paraphrase George Bush and
interview on this network back in
January he decided to run for president
or the first time he thought about
running for president with a 1997 when
his press secretary brought him a poll
that showed that he was number one in
the poll and you suggest here that polls
have changed everything they in in many
many ways I use polls a great deal I had
a sort of found struck gold at the Roper
Center at the University of Connecticut
which is the finest archive of American
polls dating back to the later 1930s
when polling began and so I was able to
find polls on everything from taste
preferences in in forms of entertainment
to attitudes towards science and
children's education and so on and on
the one hand the the polls especially
ones that are carefully crafted can
demonstrate remarkable inconsistencies
an enormous amount depends on how the
questions are phrased what's included
and what's not included in the question
nevertheless there's a tremendous amount
gets revealed when 3,000 people are
surveyed with this this
margin of error of let's say plus or
minus 4% you can learn a great deal and
and in fact in 1948 of course with the
presidential race between Dewey and
Truman the polls were dead wrong but in
1996 with Clinton's overwhelming lead
over the senior mr. Bush the polls were
incredibly accurate what's the
difference between mass culture and
popular culture that's a controversial
issue and I'm sure I know that that many
readers and fellow scholars won't agree
with my view but what what what I have
found after going through a tremendous
amount of material is that popular
culture is is more likely to be
interactive and participatory and mass
culture is more likely with some
exceptions to be passive and privatized
to give you to make that a little bit
more concrete sheet music sold in
tremendous quantity early in the 20th
century and with sheet music you needed
someone who could play the piano and
people would gather around and sing so
that sheet music lent itself to two sort
of festive socially interactive
gatherings when when recording devices
were perfected they obviously go back to
the turn of the century but there were
dramatic improvements in about nineteen
twenty twenty-one and then the long
playing record emerges in nineteen
nineteen forty-eight and anyone can turn
on a photograph but not anyone can play
the piano and anyone can sit in his or
her room and listen to a record but
that's different from a group gathering
around to to sing or going to an
amusement park together as a group which
or going to the County Fair or going to
the State Fair or going to a Wild West
Show so there's one one one difference
is certainly
difference of scale with popular culture
we're talking about thousands even
hundreds of thousands of people with
mass culture we're talking about
hundreds of millions of people and we're
also talking about a degree of
standardization and a degree of
homogeneous a tional culture that's
almost unprecedented in in our history
in our final moments tell us about this
dedication well I've been blissfully
married to Karel chemin for going on
thirty nine years now she also is a
historian and she is a playwright and
she has been she's my best critic she
has been a wonderful help with many many
projects that I have pursued and without
her I would not have two wonderful sons
and a marvelous daughter-in-law and
granddaughter so she's played a very
crucial role in my life over the more
than 40 years that I've known her what's
this piece of art on the cover that is
regiment Marcia's 20 cent movie it's
owned by the Whitney Museum of American
Art and it's a wonderful example of what
I call in the book proto mass culture
this transitional phase during the 20s
and 30s from from popular culture to
mass culture when the scale of of people
attending an event was still not massive
it's not like Monday Night Football or
the Super Bowl but it is electronic it
is it does involve films that are being
distributed all over the country but at
the same time in the early stages of
film most Americans who were middle
class and above disdained film it was
for immigrants it was for lower-class
people and it was only starting in the
1920s with the very luxurious movie
palaces that the middle class began to
go to film to watch films but from from
the beginning of silent film for almost
a quarter of a century there was a real
class segregation and how people
responded to film and early silent films
we now know from very recent scholarship
was
seating lis interactive the immigrant
audiences the working-class audiences
would scream and hiss and boo and yell
and throw things and get very very
agitated so that it was silent film was
exceedingly participatory you didn't
just sit there wearing your 3d glasses
the image that we have from the early
1950s passively watching the show in
that famous movie from was it wanted
devil I think was the film with the 3d
glasses
Michael Cameron we're out of time thank
you author of American culture American
taste social change in the 20th century
professor Kaman can be found at Cornell
University thank you thank you